you oh my
[Music]
it should be verified that so many for
me thank you very much recording of any
there from our another ally one for
speak to assist our amazing singer
brandy okay yeah hi firstly I just want
to say and I don't mean to cause you any
offence but as a non-muslim yourself I
don't know why you're always obsessed
with talking about Islam and Muslims
and yeah you can accuse before they
killed it Majid can we stick to the
budget budget you are a non-muslim I
have non-muslim friends yeah okay why do
you not talk about Christianity and
Judaism where a woman has no right to
divorce zero right to divorce you can we
talk about
no Majesty we talked about a Christian
woman and a Jewish woman has no right to
get divorce a Muslim woman has a right
to get was a jewish woman man a
Christian woman has no right to divorce
coalesced talk about the diversity don't
divert to imagine don't divert it okay
so a Jewish woman has no right to get
divorce a Christian woman
so since marginal I was really really
scared to talk about the divorce issue
because he knows he's gonna get exposed
he does not mention in Judaism a woman
has zero rights to get divorced zero
these are just some videos that you can
watch for yourself here and you can see
that it's called the get yeah the
husband needs to give the get so the
thing is they are dying to get that and
the husband is not giving it a and
they're just stuck in a marriage in
Islam you have rights many rights yeah
for a woman can get divorced
yeah they can get divorced so you can
see what kind of an islamaphobe is and
we need to tackle this cuz this is what
breed breeds hate you know towards
Muslims so now let's look at
Christianity as a Catholic Henry used to
kill his wives because wouldn't divorce
him so he fought if I kill them I can
get married again this is Jeremiah verse
chapter three verse one year if a man
divorces his wife and [ __ ] and she
leaves him and marries another man
should he return to her again yeah so if
this is a woman who's divorced with
Islamic Lee of when you divorce you can
get married again you know after it the
period their return should he return her
again
would not the land be completely defiled
but you have lived as a prostitute with
many lovers would you not return to me
declares the Lord so the woman is
classed as a prostitute for gain if she
I said it was and getting married again
a woman is bound to her husband as long
as even a
but if her husband dies she is free to
marry anyone she wishes but he must
belong to the Lord
yeah so look a woman is bound to a
husband as long as he lives so if he
dies then you can move on there's a
husband that beats meet you does
whatever you have to stick by Islam says
no you know it's time you know has the
legislation play so if your husband's
abusive beating other reasons you can't
get a divorce you can it's been said
anyone who divorces his wife must give
her a certificate of divorce but I tell
you that anyone who divorces his wife
except for sexual immorality makes her a
victim of adultery and anyone who
marries a divorced woman commits
adultery so if a woman's divorced you
marrying her means you're coming
adultery anyone who divorces his wife
and marries another woman commits
adultery and the man who marries a
divorced woman commits adultery once
again so we can clearly see why mr.
Mahina was a non-muslim is paid by the
Zionists who goes you claimed he's a
Muslim has this agenda always attacked
me Aslam never talking about these
issues and this is why we're here to
tackle this and expose him and expose
such people like him who hate preach and
who are clear hate preachers so Brahmin
sisters don't forget to help our cause
by donating to the link below
assalamualaikum what I had already
better care to hope you guys enjoyed
that video don't forget to share
subscribe and like and join the dowel
movement while becoming at our movement
member today by clicking the link below